[Music]
because there's six of us and there's
seven Thrones who's who's that for well
whoever it is I'm gonna love them no
matter what because they're an automatic
part of the family hi everyone its
charlie do you smell the crossover that
the Shazam sequels are cooking
definitely a big black atom call-out
I'll explain what the big Easter eggs
are here the post-credits teaser
basically sets up the magic lands plot
that they're doing in the comics right
now so you can actually watch that
unfold cuz it's gonna be a couple years
before the sequel gets here the black
atom movie is gonna start shooting next
year so I'll explain what it is they're
setting up and what the timeline for
black atom crossover is we're doing a
new IMAX ticket giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
us Shazam or Black Adam comment on the
video so in this deleted scene from the
Shazam movie Mary Marvel just comes to
the realization and says the thing that
most of them have probably been thinking
there are only six of us there are seven
Thrones there used to be seven wizards
who's meant to be the seventh member of
the new magical council that they formed
or the seventh member of the Shazam
family but it seems like the movies are
doing is they're sort of combining
what's going on in the comics right now
with the magic lands because of the mr.
mind post-credit scene with dr. sivana
all the realms of magic will be ours
there are get it seven realms of magic
I'll explain what the magic lands are in
a second but the post-credits scene is
about setting up Shazam - whatever that
movie winds up being mostly set into the
magic lands the Black Adam movie is
intended to be an origin story for him
he will not cross over wishes and during
that movie the sequel to that like the
third film whatever that winds up being
or at the very end of Shazam - then he
shows up then in whatever the third film
winds up being if the franchise
continues to be successful that's when
you'll see full-blown black Adam in
Shazam in a movie together as cool as
this teaser is I think the most
important part for understanding black
Adams arc through these next films where
they're intending on taking the
character eventually I mean he's an
antagonist for the most part he's a huge
badass dude that's mostly thought of as
a villain but Darla's dialogue gives you
an idea for exactly what they intend to
do with that character I'm going to love
because he's part of the family no
matter what so the whole idea is no
matter what like the stuff the black
Adam has done is terrible so she's
really calling her homerun they're like
she's really gonna have to overlook some
terrible terrible atrocities that he's
visited on the world but the whole idea
is is that the wizard gives Billy Batson
that explainer of who Black Adam is that
quick history PowerPoint tutorial using
his magic and then that's it you don't
hear any other reference to him until
you get to this deleted scene which
presumably would have happened right at
the end of the movie and I think they
probably just cut it out because they
were saving it for the beginning of
whatever sequel was that will send them
into the magic lands the way that this
ties together with what's happening in
the Shazam comics right now is is that
they just learned that a new person
who's ruling over one of the realms of
magic inside the magic lands called the
fun lands tells them that he is the
missing seventh member of their family
while they all barrel in to the fun
lands which is basically this series of
dimensions all connected within the
sphere of the gods within the larger DC
multiverse it's the part of the
multiverse where all the higher beings
live like you have the monitors you have
Darkseid the forces of apokolips
highfather New Genesis people on that
level of power so within it you have
seven interconnected dimensions of magic
but the way it's visualized within the
rock of eternity is by this big map here
with the interconnected cosmic train
that takes them from realm to realm
between dimensions the rock of eternity
itself is sort of a nexus for all magic
in the multiverse so it's connected to
everything so you could find doors to
pretty much any dimension anywhere you
want to go the reason why I think the
Black Adam is eventually intended to be
revealed as the seventh member of their
family the missing seventh member is
because I think that this new kid called
King kid who says that he's the seventh
member is actually lying to them when
they meet him for the first time he
explains that it's this dimension of fun
and he takes in lost children who are
from terrible homes he tries to give
them a very fun life but secretly you
learned that he hates adults so the
minute that the kids that live there
turn 18 he forces them to work in his
underground mines that keep the fun
lands running so imagine an evil person
ruling over Disneyland that only allows
children in in the minute that they grow
to adulthood he forces them to work
underground
so clearly he's probably lying to them
about a couple other things the funny
thing too is is that the seventh member
is actually represented by the
exclamation point in the logo Shazam the
actual name isn't just the SH a Z am so
think about it this way black Adam lost
his family his wife that's why within
the world of the DC Universe here as the
wizard tells it he unleashed the seven
deadly sins his revenge on mankind so he
has no family and he's an orphan just
like all the other members of the Shazam
family until like Darla says the Shazam
family tries to make him feel like he's
part of their family or at least tried
to because black Adam is mostly an
antagonist for them in the comics so
it's not like they're gonna warm up to
him right away and he's gonna
immediately accept their invitation to
become part of their family you got to
get through a whole lot of Hadouken and
a whole lot of punching before that can
happen but when you think about this
overall arc over whatever trilogy of
Shazam movies they might be doing you
have the idea like the second movie we
meet Shazam they fight for a little
while by the third film and then some
bigger threaten manifests within the
seven realms of magic the magic lands in
black Adam has to team up with the
Shazam family to stop it because as part
of this comic book arc black Adam shows
up after the Shazam Lee has gone into
the magic lands and thinks oh my god
what are you doing you're going to
unleash all these horrors on the world
there's a reason why the council of
wizard separated the magic lands from
the physical realm so he's actually
trying to help the world by rushing in
after the Shazam family to stop them
from unleashing all this terrible stuff
they'll probably change a couple things
about the comics but like you look at
the symbols representing the seven
different realms of magic it's the same
symbols on each of the Thrones where the
Council of wizards sit now it's a little
bit different in the movie the way they
position the Thrones so it's not a
one-to-one comparison but you just have
to imagine that each of the different
members of the Shazam family and black
Adam will probably be responsible for
protecting and guarding each of the
seven different realms of the magic
lands this is that clip that he posted
talking about the black out of movie a
little while ago after Shazam came out
it has great heart and heart
and can we if you gots it I can't wait
to play black Adam because they're all
getting their ass kicked when I play by
the black Adam that day of reckoning is
coming for everyone anyway guys thank
you again and Zack our star
congratulations buddy you did it very
happy very proud and everybody around
the world thank you again and right now
the only other things that we know about
the Black Adam movie are that is
supposed to shoot next year Hawkman was
rumored to be in it star girl we don't
know about any of the other characters
they haven't announced anyone yet they
just hired a director so maybe they'll
start announcing more characters before
the end of the year but there won't be a
teaser for it for a quite a while maybe
Comic Con next year sometime but if you
spotted any other big Easter eggs in
these clips that I posted just let me
know in the comments and let me know if
you want me to do more Shazam deleted
scenes because they just drunk a whole
bunch my next video will be my Spider
Man far from home post-credit scene that
I'll start doing Easter eggs be sure to
go see that movie as soon as possible
while you wait for everything click here
for those brand new Avengers and game
post-credit scenes and click here for
that brand new Marvel phase for Comic
Con panel that I just uploaded thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight